[Applause]
hello America I'm Jimmy faer the king of
late night Greg Gutfeld is out and
that's a good thing because he would
totally trash this jacket from my
overweight figure skater
collection like listen folks Greg bash
is my wardrobe a lot but in my defense
unlike Greg I can't borrow clothes from
Peter
Dinklage
shimmy
anyway we have a great show for you
tonight with a sexy ass panel but before
we get to them it is Friday now the
normal tradition on gut felds that we'd
open with leftovers but seeing as it's
the last episode of 2023 The Producers
agreed to let me share my final thoughts
on the year if it's okay with you
people B's final
thoughts now to be honest 2023 was a bit
of a dumpster fire but it did teach us a
lot of things for instance Bud Light
taught us that this was not what
customers meant when they asked a
bartender for a beer with some
[Laughter]
nuts so silly yeah the dill M story
turned the king of beers into the Rodney
King of
beers but the craziest part is they gave
mulvania commemorative can to celebrate
one year of Womanhood so technically
speaking they were giving beer to a
woman one-year-old
girl not sure that's what alcohol ads
meant by drink responsibly but here we
are Don Lemon taught us it's possible to
suck so bad that even CNN will fire
you lemon if you remember got into hot
water after saying Nikki Haley was
pasture Prime first off anyone who tells
you women over 50 or past their Prime
has never seen my search
history
but second Don Lemon dude you endorsed
kamla Harris We'll ask your opinion on
women once we get OJ's take on
marriage Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey
taught us that it's still legal to like
white people go figure who knew who knew
we're still a thing uh sure the mayor of
Boston had a Christmas party where no
white people were allowed but as moves
go the Boston mayor is at like a five on
a scale of one to
Harvard yeah Harvard's president CLA and
gay came under Fire after failing to
condemn anti-Semitism in a disastrous
appearance before Congress on the plus
side now we know why she plagiarized the
rest of her
speeches although in her defense she
didn't think she could write them
herself because as a Hamas supporter she
didn't know women were allowed in
libraries oh oh okay H can we have
security look at the groaners on that
one the pro Hamas recipients of that
joke not something I budgeted for as for
Taylor and Travis though I do get it
this couple is everywhere and a lot of
football fans are annoyed that they keep
showing tayor at all the games but you
got to admit it's nice to see someone
pretending to be a chief besides this
lady
jimy Jimmy so silly Palestinian
protesters taught us that you don't have
to be smart to get into an Ivy League
College check this out seriously if
there was any doubt about how dumb these
protesters were it all went out the
window when they confronted Alec Baldwin
about ending the bombings in Gaza Earth
to protesters Alec Baldwin couldn't get
a ceasefire on his own movie
[Applause]
set I doubt going to Cal things down in
the Middle East you know what I'm saying
with all due respect to the shooting
star uh
anyway speaking of movies Barbie was the
big winner at the box office this year
raking in $ 1.4 billion doll worldwide
how about it uh Republicans loved it
because Margo Robbie is a smoke show
let's be honest uh while liberals loved
going to the theater because they
finally found a way to be surrounded by
underage girls without flying all the
way to Epstein
Island
coincidentally this is interesting
Barbie brought in more money at the box
office than any film since Titanic which
continued to shatter records this
[Applause]
year
Jimmy they're just jokes everybody's
going to be okay there's no way any of
you are rich enough to know people on
that sub so
relax
but while we're talking money we should
mention that a 2023 saw a Florida man
when the biggest Mega Millions jackpot
in history at $1.6 billion Lottery
officials say the man's trying to remain
anonymous and he set up an LLC in
Delaware to hide the money as you'd
imagine he's reaching out to the experts
on hiding money in Delaware
uh so
silly yeah it wasn't exactly a banner
year in politics Donald Trump became the
first president to be criminally
indicted and Joe Biden became the first
president to make a sign language
interpreter
[Laughter]
shrug yo true story at the State of the
Union his second to last line was Now's
the Time to choose between unity and
schm ham ham
H and it's a state of the union so they
all clap but if you watch the sign
language interpreter she goes from
signing to like Google cuz she's like I
don't know what this means
like come to think of it it might have
been the sign language interpreter's
cocaine at the White House after all
that as for Trump looking back on the
historic day of his indictment if we're
being honest the most shocking part of
his flight to New York was seeing a
president making up the steps of the
plane in one
try and finally 2023 taught us that
literally anyone can write a
book I'm going to get us out of this
mesh shut up and just when you thought
the bar couldn't get any
lower now let's let's get real for a
minute you should buy cat's book because
she's profoundly talented she's a
bestselling author she sells out
stand-up shows all over the country do
you want to know why you should buy my
book for real just so you can see how
out of place it is on the Fox News books
website go to that site you're going to
every the first book is like Shannon
bream women of the Bible speak Harris
fauler f can move mountains Jimmy faella
a hooker farted on a guy in my
cast I don't know what it's doing there
but but buy it check it out yeah 2023
was the type of crazy ass story that you
couldn't make up unless you were George
Santos
um got to hit the Republicans kids
that's how Comedy
Works now the House of Representatives
voted to expel the Holocaust Survivor
turned astronaut and
uh
and let's be clear though like Santos
lied way too much like you know it's bad
when Lauren bobbert says you're yanking
our
chain boubert famously got caught feling
a man's privates in a Denver movie
theater Republicans were upset that she
performed a sex act in public Democrats
were angry that she didn't show the
video to kindergarten kids
um coincidentally bber did it during a
screening of Beetle Juice which is not
exactly the sexiest show in town if you
don't believe me you've never seen what
beatle juice looks
like
Jimmy and finally a tip of the cap to
New Jersey Senator Bob Menendez who
showed us that it really is possible to
get the gold bars out of
Nigeria now millions of Americans are
receiv received spam emails over the
years and come up empty but not Menendez
and sure he was criminally indicted
afterwards but he hasn't been forced to
resign because if 20123 taught us
anything it's that liberals have no
problem with men going for the gold as
long as they take it from a
woman he
is all right let's welcome tonight's
guest if political pundants were wine
she'd be the nicest box on the Shelf Fox
News anchor Julie Banderas in the house
he's a kick-ass comedian who looks like
the guy hunter buys crack from comedian
Jim
Florentine he always kills on stage and
not just because he looks like a Civil
War General actor and standup comedian
Tyler
fiser and her New Year's resolution is
to be less awesome New York Times
bestselling author and Fox News
contributor C timer and The Crowd Goes
Wild all right so Julie we covered a lot
there when you look back on 2023 if
someone gave this to you as a gift would
you keep it or would you regift it I
would regift it like to an enemy you
know like you don't give 2023 to anyone
you have any respect for so probably I'd
give it to my ex-husband
202 2023 is the fruit cake of years I
dig it yeah I liked the Don Lemon story
though I I just want to address that
he's calling Nikki Haley actually uh out
of her prime he's passed his prime I
just wanted to put that on the record
glad we got that out of the way well I
feel like it needed to be said great to
see I it yeah uh
Florentine uh as a nationally touring
comedian people like to say this is like
the best time to be a comic because
there's so much stupid stuff going on
but is it actually the opposite because
it's almost hard to keep up with
Ridiculousness it is and then people are
afraid to laugh at something especially
with the Bud Light stuff yeah yeah not
this crowd give them credit I know oh my
God I was like
yo you cannot offend this crowd we tried
everything people at home don't know
this we opened by clubbing a baby seal
they didn't even care they were like no
hit him again I actually love that the
only thing they were offended by was you
saying I was a bad
writer and you know I didn't mean that I
love all of you come over after yeah
that's H oh no you should if you guys
like math you're going to love this
party but it is I'm way class
but it is it's a stupid time to be alive
is it it is but like if I made a joke
about Bud Light if I said some guy in
the front's drinking a Bud Light at the
comedy show I go you want me to you want
you you need to tell me something you
might as well get out in the open right
now they'll just like oh how can you say
that now as a comedian Tyler though
aren't you thankful for the
decision-making process of the parent
company Tran Heiser Bush Tran Heiser
Bush well I you know what I I think they
made a big M Barbie made a big mistake
they should have had Dylan mulany play
Barbie because he's 90% plastic at this
point right they could have saved money
he could have played Barbie and Ken
right called it barbon
himmer I like that was a great and then
they only played on the Gaza Strip and
they don't let old white women in we
could have combined it all into one
timesaving thing but cat didn't Dylan
Mulaney kind of destroy the gender pay
Gap and that he was a man for 27 years
no one knew who he was he was a woman
for a year he made 10 million
bucks so I wasn't as into talking about
the D M thing it's whatever it doesn't
matter however I think it's interesting
that they chose if they wanted to have a
trans person for their ad they chose you
know a a male to female trans person and
not the other way around they could have
done like a for 100 you know days of
being a bro like it's a broy brand it's
blood light and as a woman who was born
a woman and is still extremely
broy I don't know why I would miss out
on opportunity like that or other people
cuz it's like nobody who is campy is
drinking Bud Light no it's true
regardless of gender but that's what I
think these Brands screw up it's they
try to Plate the people who don't
actually partake in what they're doing
isn't that it's so stupid well that that
podcast that the marketing person
actually said that like we we want she
did a podcast where she said she was
trying to turn she thought the consumer
that chose the product was disgusting
yeah but also it was all about business
she never at any point said I really
actually care about trans people so
businesses are businesses their aim is
to make money so that shouldn't be
shocking what's shocking to me is when
people think businesses care about you
oh yeah they don't care at all they're
all that's a great point but I do agree
on to our commercial break didn't didn't
Disney kind of learn that message like
you're supposed to do what makes you
money like people go to Disney because
they like rides they want to pay $32 for
a turkey leg and Marvel at the fat
people on scooters isn't that why you go
yeah but like no one was waiting in line
3 hours to go on Snow White in the 7 in
you know what I'm saying so do you think
this was the year Florentine that's
going to kind of scare company straight
I think so I think after the Bud Light
thing cuz it's still down like 25% I
love going to the liquor store and just
going to the Beer section and seeing the
Bud Light stack to the ceiling and the
corona is way down here I love seeing
that that's great it's got to hurt your
feelings as a bud like eye because I'll
tell you this the thing that hurt me the
most JB my car once got stolen in the
city and if you live in the city you're
like just once really um my car once got
stolen in the city they threw my CD out
of the tape player like they were like
I'm I'm stealing your car but I'm not a
dirt bag I'm not going to listen to
Jimmy's Color Me Bad summer miix
92 and they ditch my music why would
anyone want to steal a Toyota Camry well
it's have things went on in that Camry
as you know a former New York City cab
driver I've had thousands of women in my
back seat technically speaking anyway on
that mediocre Splash before we go a
quick reminder my new book The cancel
culture dictionary comes out January 3D
it is an a toz guide on how to take back
some fun in our woke world so don't
forget to pre-order your copy now look
at me folks I need all the help I can
get hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else